c'est un avertissement envoyé par
sergueï lavrov au monde entier pour le
chef de la diplomatie russe il y a un
réel danger que le conflit dégénère en
troisième guerre mondiale mais il assure
il veut poursuivre les négociations de
paix avec ukraine
le danger est grave il est réel on ne
peut pas le sous-estimer
mais nous continuons de mener des
négociations avec l'équipe délégué par
le président ukrainien volodimir
zelensky et ses contacts vont se
poursuivre des propos qui font écho à
ceux de volodymyr zelensky dans une
vidéo publiée lundi soir sur ces réseaux
sociaux
tout le monde à travers la planète
même ceux qui ne nous soutenaient pas
ouvertement s'accorde désormais à dire
que c'est en ukraine que se joue le
destin de l'europe le destin la sécurité
mondiale et le sort du système
démocratique
ces déclarations interviennent au
lendemain de la visite à kiev du
secrétaire d'état américain anthony
blinken et de lloyd austin le chef du
pentagone ils ont rencontré le président
ukrainien une première depuis l'invasion
de l'ukraine
au retour de cette visite lloyd austin
estime que kiev ou gagner cette guerre
la première chose pour gagner c'est de
croire que l'on peut gagner et les
ukrainiens sont convaincus qu'ils
peuvent gagner nous pensons qu'ils
peuvent gagner s'ils ont le bon
équipement le bon soutien et nous allons
faire tout ce que nous pouvons continuer
à faire tout ce que nous pouvons pour
nous assurer que cela arrive les
etats-unis ont accéléré leurs livraisons
d'équipements militaires à l'ukraine des
armes lourdes pour contrer l'offensive
russe que le président ukrainien ne
cessé de réclamer
une